David Boder: [In English] Munich, September the 24th, 1946, at the UNRRA University in the Deutsches Museum, a university for displaced students from all over the world; about more than a dozen nationalities. The interviewee is a gentleman, Valerius Michelson.
David Boder: [In German] Wie alt sind Sie?
David Boder: [In English] Thirty years of age, a student at the university, and he is Lithuanian? Or Latvian?
Valerius Michelson: No, Russian.
David Boder: Or...or he is Russian!
David Boder: [In Russian] Тогда, может быть, по-русски говорить будем дальше?
Valerius Michelson: Ну конечно.
David Boder: И он будет говорить с нами по-русски. Говорите. Возьмите так. Господин Михельсон, я бы Вас попросил [пауза] сказать мне, где Вы были и что с Вами произошло...эээ...с того моментакак...эээ...началась или война, или движение советских войск по направлению к западу.
Valerius Michelson: Я в это время находился в Эстонии.
David Boder: А где в Эстонии?
Valerius Michelson: В городе Ревеле. Или Таллинне.
David Boder: Так. А Вы...эээ...с каких пор жили в Ревеле?
Valerius Michelson: Я жил с 19го года.
David Boder: Значит, прямо после первой революции.
Valerius Michelson: Да.
David Boder: Жили Вы с Вашими родителями там?
Valerius Michelson: Я жил вместе с [неразборчиво]
David Boder: И вот, значит, в каком году...эээ...Советы пришли в Ревель? Первый раз?
Valerius Michelson: В 39ом году.
David Boder: Хорошо. [Неразборчиво]? Что Вы тогда делали? И так далее.
Valerius Michelson: Я в это время находился в Ревеле. И [пауза] занимался, собственно, тем, что рисовал и так далее. Я готовился к тому, чтобы в скором времени окончить техническую школу в Ревеле.
David Boder: Так. Вы были студентом?
Valerius Michelson: Я был студентом.
David Boder: С этого и начните. Вы были студентом технической школы в Ревеле и были близко к окончанию.
Valerius Michelson: Был близко к окончанию.
David Boder: Хорошо. Что с Вами лично случилось, с Вашими ближними, семьёй, когда Советы пришли в Ревель?
Valerius Michelson: Мы вначале ожидали Советов как русских [пауза] и поэтому радовались приходу. Но [пауза] в очень скором времени убедились в том, что тут то радоваться особенно не приходилось. Мой отец был редактором русской газеты в Ревеле.
David Boder: Как газета называлась?
Valerius Michelson: Газета называлась «Свобода России».
David Boder: В Ревеле?! Она называлась «Свобода России»?!
Valerius Michelson: Да.
David Boder: А как же эстонцы такую газету позволяли? Или что это было? Ах, да! Это было...под свободой России подразумевалась свобода от Советов.
Valerius Michelson: Нет, это была газета довольно левая.
David Boder: Так.
Valerius Michelson: Но она была очень закрытой [неразборчиво].
Valerius Michelson: Причем такой закрытой [неразборчиво], отец работал экономистом.
David Boder: Так.
Valerius Michelson: . . . эээ...Якак раз упомянул эту газету, потому что она была чрезвычайно левого направления. Отец был в своё время эсером и поэтому сочувствовал движению в России и полагал, что, если не большевизм прямо, то, во всяком случае, социалистическая революция в России необходима. Я был воспитан тоже в этих взглядах. И считал себя всегда...эээ...человеком не...во всяком случае, не...эээ...фашистского или даже не капиталистического толка. [Пауза] Тем не менее, после прихода Советов в Эстонию [пауза] в очень скором времени у отца началися неприятности [пауза] и к концу...в начале 40го года...
Valerius Michelson: . . . его вызвали...два раза вызывали в...в органы НКВД...
David Boder: Что это такое – НКВД?
Valerius Michelson: Это...эээ...ммм...Народный Комиссариат...
David Boder: Советская полиция или что-то?
Valerius Michelson: . . . Внутренних Дел республики. Это своего рода...да, своего рода советское гестапо, что ли. [Со смехом]
David Boder: Да. [Неразборчиво, очень тихо]
Valerius Michelson: Я не знаю. Это в своё время называлося ГПУ, а затем было переименовано. Когда, я не знаю точно, во всяком случае, когда они пришли туда, то там были и пограничные войска, и...эээ...такая...эээ...тайная полиция. Тогда они все носили одно и то же название [неразборчиво]. [Пауза] И затем [пауза] март 41го года отец, уходя на службу утром, конечно, не ожидал, что он не вернется назад. Он исчез, и с тех пор я о нём не имел никаких известий. [Пауза]
David Boder: Ни Вы, ни Ваша мать, никто.
Valerius Michelson: Ни я, - мать у меня уже умерла раньше, - я не получал больше никаких известий.
David Boder: Кто у Вас в семье был [неразборчиво]?
Valerius Michelson: У меня была тётя, которая меня воспитывала. [Пауза] И которой затем удалось уехать в Финляндию. [Пауза]
David Boder: Вы от неё [неразборчиво]?
Valerius Michelson: Я...эээ...от неё получил письмо, пересланное мной моим двоюродным братом из Бельгии. У меня три двоюродных брата, которые сейчас в Бельгии, и через них я получил эти письма, потому что прямой связи сейчас с Финляндией нет. [Пауза] Ну, после этого, Вы знаете,...эээ...к осени, довольно ранней осени, [пауза] в августе...в конце июля, начале августа пришли немцы.
David Boder: Так. [Пауза] Так отец Ваш не вернулся? Вы не наводили о нём никаких справок? Не расспросили...?
Valerius Michelson: Я пытался расспросить, но не получил никаких известий. Меня даже вызывали два раза и допрашивали относительно будто бы антисоветского движения отца и работы, которую [неразборчиво]
David Boder: Да.
Valerius Michelson: Но меня отпустили, потому что я в это время был довольно самостоятельный, не жил с ним вместе и, вероятно, меня не сочли ни в чём особо виновным. Я...
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Valerius Michelson: Да, да. Я лично думаю, что [пауза] отец едва ли вёл какую-то антисоветскую работу, потому что он, во-первых, был уже довольно стар, а во-вторых, по своим убеждениям, мне думается, не мог быть противником советской власти.
David Boder: Вы какого вероисповедания?
Valerius Michelson: Православный.
David Boder: Я спрашиваю, какого вероисповедания [неразборчиво]
Valerius Michelson: Ну, вот. Я сказал щас – православный, но я не хочу утверждать этого совершенно определённо: я крещён как православный, но...
David Boder: Я понимаю. Это Ваша семья. Семейный background православный.
Valerius Michelson: Да. Совершенно верно. [Пауза] Ну, затем [пауза] уже тогда, как начали вызывать в НКВД и так далее, и так далее – это не давало мне покоя и...эээ...положение у нас финансовое было скверное [пауза]. Мне пришлося довольно много работать. И главным образом, делать такого рода рисунки, картины и так далее для того, чтобы зарабатывать.
David Boder: Ну, дальше, значит.
Valerius Michelson: Я это продолжал делать и до того момента, когда пришли немцы. [Пауза]
David Boder: Подождите-ка,...
Valerius Michelson: Да?
David Boder: мне это интересует. Эээ...Советы были, значит, в Ревеле...
Valerius Michelson: Да.
David Boder: А как жизнь...? Например, Вы работали, Вы могли продавать свои работы там, получать за это деньги; лавки были открыты. Как всё это было?
Valerius Michelson: Да, эээ...дело в том, что такого изобилия, которое было в своё время в Эстонии – как и во всех прибалтийских странах, больше не было. Но...
David Boder: Вы говорите об экономической организации?
Valerius Michelson: Да.
David Boder: Частные лавки были?
Valerius Michelson: Частные лавки оставалися, но начали закрываться. В это время пытались уже проводить, значит, своего рода, социализацию или я не знаю как это назвать – во всяком случае,...
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Valerius Michelson: . . . эээ...государ...эээ...превращать все эти отдельные предприятия в государственные предприятия. Одновременно...
David Boder: Но это не сразу делалось?
Valerius Michelson: Не сразу. Одновременно открылися и магазины, которые...ммм...в которых торговали приехавшие из России люди.
David Boder: То есть как, от себя торговали?!
Valerius Michelson: Нет, в качестве государственных предприятий.
David Boder: Как кооперативы?
Valerius Michelson: Как кооперативы или, я бы сказал, что это даже выгодно...я бы сказал, что...эээ...собственно, не кооперативы. Потому что кооператив включает в себя понятие члена, пайщика и так далее, чего в этих магазинах не было.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 153, in the middle of an interview with Mr. Valerius Michelson, age 30, a student of the UNRRA University at the Deutsches Museum in Munich. September the 24th, 1946. An Illinois Institute wire recording. [Pause] Spool 154. We continue from Spool 153. The interview with Mr. Valecius Michel...Valerius Michelson. Mr. Michelson is apparently an important person [pause] in the life of the university, and he has an urge to talk about it. Well, we will try to see what we can get in...ahm in this short program, because we have changed our rule, and instead of letting everybody talk as long as possible, we are taking them in long half hour turns, because it simply would be a very great hardship to them of not having listened to the representative of each nationality. Maybe scientifically this would not be so immediately convertible in useful material, but we just have to do it.
David Boder: Spool 154. We continue from Spool 153. The interview with Mr. Valecius Michel...Valerius Michelson. Mr. Michelson is apparently an important person [pause] in the life of the university, and he has an urge to talk about it. Well, we will try to see what we can get in...ahm in this short program, because we have changed our rule, and instead of letting everybody talk as long as possible, we are taking them in one half hour turns, because it simply would be a very great hardship to them of not having listened to the representative of each nationality. Maybe scientifically this wouldn’t be so immediately convertible into useful material, but we just have to do it.
David Boder: [In Russian] Итак, значит, господин Михельсон, возьмём те пока так. Значит...эээ..., отца Вашегоотец Ваш исчез во время Советов?
Valerius Michelson: Да.
David Boder: Вы пробивались, делая рисунки и...эээ...картины тоже?
David Boder: Для кого Вы это делали?
Valerius Michelson: Я их делал для свободной продажи.
David Boder: Так.
Valerius Michelson: Продавал их у...частью у знакомых, а частью через них доставал людей, которые интересуются этим. И это же продолжал делать, когда пришли немцы.
David Boder: Хорошо. Вот скажите, как немцы пришли. Как был этот переворот?
Valerius Michelson: Видите, подробностей я рассказать не могу, потому что мы...
David Boder: Нет, я не хочу общих. Как...? В той среде, где Вы были – были люди которые бежали, были люди, которых эвакуировали? Как всё это было?
Valerius Michelson: Те люди, которые пришли с...с советской стороны – их было довольно много, - у меня было некоторые знакомые оттудова, [пауза] они почти все бежали раньше. Осталось очень малое количество.
David Boder: Так.
Valerius Michelson: Что же касается до...так называемая...старой русской иммиграции, которая там была, она в большинстве своём осталася и частью даже радовалась приходу немцев. Но не все. Я в это время был погружен, конечно, в хозяйственные заботы, потому что с уходом отца наше положение чрезвычайно ухудшилось. Эээ...тётя, с которой я вместе жил, очень старая уже, и она не могла, конечно, каким-то образом помогать мне, и мне приходилось прокармливать и её, и себя. И поэтому мне при...очень мало приходилось вести разговоров с людьми посторонними, только случайно. Во всяком случае, до прихода немцев я полагал, что будут довольно сильные бои там и постарался, вместе с моей тётей – так как мы жили за городом, - выбраться ещё дальше в предместье города Ревеля, в [неразборчиво].
Valerius Michelson: И там, собственно, мы и пережили весь приход [смеётся] немцев. Боёв никаких больших в Ревеле не было в это время и...и всё произошло довольно тихо. Эээ...незадолго до прихода немцев меня поражала страшная растерянность советской...советских солдат, армии и некоторых судов, стоящих на рейде в ревельской бухте.
Valerius Michelson: Эээ...они...эээ...насколько я знаю, не имели возможности выехать, потому что не имели горючего. И вот мне приходилось буквально на улицах слышать о том, как, значит, что люди [неразборчиво, очень тихо] где раздобыть горючее, что нам его не дают...
David Boder: [Неразборчиво] или масло?
Valerius Michelson: Не знаю. Масло, очевидно, масло или керосин. И так далее. Я жил на побережье на самом. Эээ...на берегу залива и мог наблюдать, как...это самое...несколько раз маневрировали суда, как ночью выезжали оттудова для того, чтобы ввозить горючее с берега, потому что в это время уже немецкие самолёты пыталисябомбардировать эти самые суда. То же самое происходило и в войсках внизу...эээ...т.е. не внизу, собственно, а на берегу, где...эээ...очень странно металися взад и вперёд фигуры отдельных, очевидно, посыльных или кого-то в этом духе, которые производили впечатление страшно напуганных и страшно растерянных людей.
David Boder: Ну да, это общая такая Ваша чёрная картина. Ну, значит, пришли немцы, и Вы продолжали работать своим образом.
Valerius Michelson: Да.
David Boder: Что же сейчас случилось с Вами?
Valerius Michelson: Со мной лично...я вернулся на свою квартиру, на свои две комнаты с тётей и продолжал там жить вместе, и продолжал там делать эти самые картинки и так далее, причём никаких особых...эээ...неудобств со стороны немцев вначале не замечал.
David Boder: Что случилось потом?
Valerius Michelson: Потом...это продолжалося примерно до...эээ...начала 42го года, то есть почти целый год. Нет, меньше, чем год. [Пауза] После этого я был вызван...эээ...в арбайтсамт в самом городе. Приехал туда, и мне там предложили ряд вопросов о том, чем я занимаюсь и так далее, и так далее и сказали, что, собственно – я по-немецки говорил прилично тогда, потому что я учился в своё время в немецкой гимназии [неразборчиво] шуле, -...
David Boder: Где? В Ревеле?
Valerius Michelson: В Ревеле, да. И...эээ...значит...эээ...собственно говоря, что это неважная работа и так далее, и так далее. Спросили меня, кто я по национальности. Я сказал, что русский. Составили соответствующую карточку и предложили прийти ещё через неделю. Когда я пришёл через неделю, мне вручили...эээ...такую...как бы сказать [со смехом]...бумажку, в общем, такого содержания или приказ о том, что я должен выехать на работу в Австрию или, значит, они не говорили в Австрию, а назвали город просто – в Линц, на...куда я и отправился ещё через три дня.
David Boder: Хм. Это называли Остмарк [неразборчиво]? И что, Вы сами отправились или с эшелоном?
Valerius Michelson: Нет, там поехало довольно большое количество. Причем, некоторые из людей были тоже...эээ...знакомые мои...эээ...по Ревелю.
David Boder: А как все везли? Какие вагоны? И как условия были?
Valerius Michelson: Эээ...условия поездки были довольно приличные. Вагоны были, правда, товарные, но с нарами и так далее. И кроме того,...эээ...мы получали еду по дороге [пауза] среднего качества, но во всяком случае голодными не были.
David Boder: Били кого-нибудь?
Valerius Michelson: Нет. [Пауза] Единственное неудобство было, что выходить было почти невозможно, кроме как на...в таких...эээ...случаях, когда мы долгое время стояли. И это послужило для меня причиной несчастья: я вышел...эээ...около Вены – я не знаю точно, как называлось маленькое местечко, но непосредственно около Вены, – там мы стояли в течение трёх дней и значит, выходили для того, чтобы вымыться и привести себя в порядок. И около...эээ...водокачки, у которой [со смехом] мы мылися во время аранжировки состава, меня толкнул вагон, я упал и переломил себе ногу. И поэтому с эшелоном дальше не был направлен. А был отправлен сначала...эээ...в небольшую больницу или что-то в этом духе в этой...в этом маленьком селении или пригороде Вены, а затем переправлен в самую Вену, в Самаритана госпиталь. [Пауза] Потом я...меня положили в гипс; я довольно долгое время находился там и при этом...эээ...довольно хорошо за мной ухаживали, тем более после того, как я попросил бумагу и начал рисовать всех, кто там был из моих сиделок, потом врача-хирурга – молодого, очень симпатичного врача, который за мной ухаживал. И с этим врачом я настолько впоследствии подружился, что он мне предложил остаться – врач был активист – предложил мне остаться в Вене и помогать работать его жене, которая занималася кунстгевербе. Таким образом, я остался в Вене. Через знакомство этого врача мне удалося устроить через арбайтсамт, я считался...эээ...так сказать, человеком свободной профессии и мог заниматься в течение последующих трёх лет тем, чем я начал заниматься в Ревеле, т.е. рисованием всякого рода картинок и тому подобного.
David Boder: Так. Вы, значит были...эээ...так сказать, коллегой Гитлера – он же тоже был артист.
Valerius Michelson: Да, приблизительно. Только с той разницей, что [со смехом] я занимался рисованием картинок, я он занимался...
David Boder: Так. Ну, дальше.
Valerius Michelson: И вот значит...теперь так.
David Boder: А где Вы были в момент освобождения?
Valerius Michelson: В момент освобождения. Я был всё время в Вене, до того момента, когда к ней...к Вене стали приближаться большевики. Так как я знал Советы по...моим переживаниям в Ревеле, или вернее по переживаниям моего отца – т.е. это были только переживания, а не просто конечные, смертельные сводки – этого я не знаю,- я не захотел остаться в Вене и выбрался оттуда вместе с целым потоком бегущих из Вены. И передвигался оттудова на запад. [Пауза] Эээ...в начале мая, примерно числа шестого, я перешёл через баварскую границу [пауза] и [неразборчиво]
David Boder: [Неразборчиво] Вы нелегально пошли, значит, на Запад?
Valerius Michelson: Я пошёл нелегально, вместе, как я говорю, со всеми этими бесконечными эшелонами. Причём мне удалося часть дороги проехать вместе со своими соотечественниками, которые бежали откуда-то из России, близ Смоленска.
David Boder: Так.
Valerius Michelson: С которыми мне удалось [со смехом] беседовать по пути, и которые мне передали о Советской России масса всяких печальных вещей и говоря о том, что они остались без...без Родины, без всего. Когда я их спрашивал, почему же, собственно, зачем же они уходили с Родины? Они говорили, что им также тяжело там оста...осталось быть...как бы сказать?
David Boder: Стало бы жить.
Valerius Michelson: . . . стало бы жить, как и здесь, на чужбине. С ними я потом расстался. И вместе с одним человеком ещё двигался через разрушенный Мюнхен – это было так: я только что успел перейти границу между...эээ...Австрией и Баварией, как встретил первые американские части.
David Boder: Так просто?!
Valerius Michelson: Да.
David Boder: Ну, а потом как Вы в Мюнхен попали?
Valerius Michelson: Я...эээ...затем уже передвигался в...на юг Баварии и дошёл, частью доехал до Кемптена. В Кемптене я пошёл в лагерь...эээ...ДП, в котором пробыл восемь дней. Жизнь в лагере была для меня страшно тяжёлой.
David Boder: Но что Вы ели на дороге? Как Вы...?
Valerius Michelson: По дороге я питался самым разнообразным образом. До тех пор, пока я добрался до американских частей, я питался преимущественно таким образом, что заходил к отдельным крестьянам и просил у них что-либо и так далее. И надо сказать, что в Австрии в этом отношении люди были гораздо более милыми, чем затем в Баварии.
David Boder: Так.
Valerius Michelson: Но в Баварии я пробыл один день без американцев. Там был страшный такой сумбур и...эээ...я не удивлялся тому, что никто не заботится о том, чтоб меня накормить, потому что все люди были в страшной тревоге и боязни.
David Boder: Немцы?
Valerius Michelson: Немцы.
David Boder: А войска где были?
Valerius Michelson: Войска...эээ...мне пришлось их встретить только в одном из сёл, в которые шёл я. Я старался не ходить по главным дорогам, потому что я шёл, конечно, без документов, и это было бы опасно. И я думаю, что я...мне удалось пройти только потому, что как раз всех мучило такое странное и напряжённое настроение. [Пауза] Эээ...во всяком случае, по большим дорогам я пытался не ходить, а старался идти от хутора к хутору по мелким деревушкам.
David Boder: Так.
Valerius Michelson: И таким образом...эээ...пропитался до того момента, когда встретил первую американскую часть. Первая же американская часть снабдила меня сухими пакетами, и на этих сухих пакетах я добрался до юга Баварии в Кемптен.
David Boder: Пешком или...?
Valerius Michelson: Частично на автомобиле. Один кусочек через...от границы Баварии и до...эээ...Мюнхена и через Мюнхен ещё маленький кусок я проехал на автомобиле, на американском грузовике. А затем...после этого, ещё прошёл кусочек, причём это было самая интересная часть моей последней жизни. В это время у меня была с собой бумага, была акварель, я зарисовывал всякого рода...эээ...дома отдельные, которые меня поражали и интересовали. Зарисовывал картинки быта в Баварии. Это было очень интересно, и я чувствовал себя действительно – в первый раз после многих лет - свободным и одержанным...полным надежд на будущее.
David Boder: Так. Ну, скажите мне вот что. [Пауза]...эээ...Вы сказали, что Вы хотите кое-что сказать о Ваш...о УНРРА университете. Вы сами на каком факультете?
Valerius Michelson: На архитектурном факультете.
David Boder: На архитектурном. Я так и подозревал, но не хотел делать никаких заключений. Ну, возьмемте 10 минут и скажите мне что-нибудь об университете.
Valerius Michelson: Хорошо. Я не хотел, собственно, говорить об университете. Я хотел сказать о том, что меня лично интересует...
David Boder: Да, не что в университете.
Valerius Michelson: Я уже говорил о том, что в Кемптене я попал в лагерь. Я...
David Boder: Кемптон?
Valerius Michelson: Кемптон.
David Boder: Где это?
Valerius Michelson: Это в Альсгай, на юге Баварии. В лагерь ДП [неразборчиво]. Я выдержал в этом лагере ровным счётом восемь дней. Потому что жить, ничего не делая, получать пособия не за что – это было для меня настолько мучительно! Самая жизнь с людьми, которые не видят для себя никакого выхода, ни видят, что они могут принести пользу другим людям, начав работать, и люди, которые полагаются на то, что они...эээ...будут откуда-то получать помощь, не заслуживая её ничем, - было для меня чрезвычайно тяжело.
David Boder: Вы думаете незаслуженная или незарабатываемая?
Valerius Michelson: Незарабатываемая.
David Boder: Есть разница.
Valerius Michelson: Да, незарабатываемая.
David Boder: Вы понимаете, люди, которые были в Бухенвальде годами...
Valerius Michelson: Я бы сказал,...
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Valerius Michelson: - Люди, которые были в Бухенвальде, люди, которые тяжело работали на немцев, очень тяжело работали, - потому что я знаю очень многих людей, которым приходилося делать вещи, которые, право, едва ли какое...какая-нибудь другая нация могла заставить делать человека. Эээ...эти люди, конечно, заслужили отдых и, конечно, заслужили возможность...эээ...некоторое время.... по настоящему отдохнуть, с тем, чтобы быть в дальнейшем опять способными...эээ...к творчеству и работе. Но [пауза] я всё-таки хочу сказать, что яне только...эээ...зарабатывая, но и заслуживая хочу прибавить. Потому что я увидел в этих лагерях, и в частности в том лагере, где мне пришлось быть, громадное количество людей, которые по своей психологии, по своей [пауза]...эээ...по своему внутреннему содержанию были недостаточно высоки и морально, и...эээ...[пауза] как бы сказать, нравственно; люди, которые использовали это...эту возможность быть поддерживаемым за счёт...эээ...какого-то чужого богатства...эээ...использовали в том отношении, что [неразборчиво, очень тихо] в том отношении, что...пыталися устраивать всякого рода куплю-продажу [пауза] или...эээ...[пауза] заниматься всякого рода любовными аферами, а подчас и просто грабить окружающих крестьян и прочее. Я понимаю вспышку гнева, вспышку такого...ненависти к людям, которые нас угнетали в течение долгого времени, но обогащаться за счёт этих людей, по-моему, бесстыдно и бессовестно. И эта обстановка заставила меня уйти из лагеря. Я ушёл и сказал себе, я никогда больше не попаду в этот лагерь.
David Boder: Подождите, зададим Вам другой вопрос. Это для нас очень интересно, потому что. Вы говорите «обогащаться»:...эээ...Вы были...всё время имели возможность зарабатывать. Вас, вероятно, за всё время ни разу не ударили. Ударили Вас когда-нибудь за это время в Германии?
Valerius Michelson: Нет, нет.
David Boder: И тут Вы берёте людей, которых обыскивали, постоянно забирали вещи. Эти вещи рассылались немцам, [пауза] как подарки продавались. [Неразборчиво]
Valerius Michelson: Я это понимаю.
David Boder: И потом, значит, если они, предположим, вошли в деревню и забрали сундуки, забрали вещи...
Valerius Michelson: Это не обкрадывание.
David Boder: Так как же Вы могли сказать «обогащаться на счёт соседнего населения»?
Valerius Michelson: Я скажу другое. Это я понимаю. И я сказал, что я понимаю их вспышку гнева и понимаю ненависть к немцам. И я скажу, что я не люблю немцев, и мне они противны. И об этом я хотел говорить тогда, когда я думал сказать о том, почему я с этим университете, и почему я работаю в этом университете на моей общественной работе. Но я скажу, что для того, чтобы ответить на Ваш вопрос о том, какими способами это делалось, я знаю, что целый ряд буквально криминальных элементов, частью из Советской России, – потому что я хорошо владею русским языком, я с ними разговаривал, - я видел, что они остались...
David Boder: Это военнопленные?
Valerius Michelson: Необязательно пленные, самые разнообразные люди. Я с ними разговаривал, и я видел, каково их психологическое нутро, что они думают при этом? Они думали не о том, чтобы забрать то, что у них взято силой. Они думали о том, что они в Советской России не имеют возможности обкрадывать людей, не имеют возможности грабить, убивать. Здесь они объединялись буквально в банды для того, чтобы устраивать свои личные дела. А не для того, чтобы каким-то образом искупить то зло, которое им сделали немцы, нет. И вот этих людей я считаю, безусловно, людьми, которые не достойны поддержки какого бы ни было народа.
David Boder: Было много таких людей?
Valerius Michelson: Я полагаю, что из тех людей...я полагаю, что из тех людей, которые пришли с востока, [пауза] главным образом из советских областей, только малая часть неинтеллигентных бывали такого рода. Те, кто пришли честно сюда, которых сюда притащили...которых заставили здесь работать - крестьянство, рабочие из России, – они поехали назад. Те же, кто остался здесь, в большинстве случаев, были людьми с криминальным складом. И я считаю, что нет никаких оснований таким людям оказывать поддержку. И только те люди, которые испытывали какой-то духовный гнёт против них – и это главным образом, интеллигенция, пришедшая из Советской России, - она осталась честной и поэтому осталася и бедной, и [пауза], по большей части, не хотела жить вместе с этими элементами. [Пауза] Я встречаю этих людей сейчас довольно часто. Я знаю, что это люди из Советской России. Но я близок с ними, и я люблю с ними разговаривать, потому что вижу в них настоящие черты интеллигентных [пауза], разумных людей и знающих, почему они здесь. Я делю...эээ...людей русских, пришедших из Советской России сейчас на две категории: или на людей, которые знали, почему они сю...оттуда уходят [пауза], потому что там не было развития для их творческой способности. Не было...
David Boder: Они воспользовались приходом немцев, чтобы потом уйти из России?
Valerius Michelson: Чтобы уйти из России или, если они были силком вывезенные из России, остаться здесь. Или же частью - это элемент, который ушёл из России, потому что не находил возможности там пользоваться чужой...чужою собственностью, чужим добром и живут здесь, пользуясь изо дня в день возможностью жить не своим трудом. [Пауза] Те люди, которые пришли оттуда или были вывезены оттуда, привыкнув там работать, все хотят работать и здесь. И это главным образом интеллигентная...группа интеллигентные. Частью, конечно, и не только интеллигенция. И эти люди и сейчас работают. И они, в большинстве своих случаев, не собираются в лагерях, а стараются пробиваться к жизни как-нибудь другим способом, но вне этих людей.
David Boder: А немцы позволяют им работать тут?
Valerius Michelson: Частью, да. Это очень трудно, но возможно. Я знаю нес...целый ряд случаев, когда люди живут...эээ...вне лагеря и работают, допустим, у американских частей и...
David Boder: Ага.
Valerius Michelson: . . . или работают на американских лагерях. Это немцы запретить не могут.
David Boder: А Вы где живёте?
Valerius Michelson: Я живу около [неразборчиво]
David Boder: В общежитии?
Valerius Michelson: Частным образом, как и большинство наших студентов.
David Boder: Не с УНРРА?
Valerius Michelson: Не с УНРРА.
David Boder: Как же...Вас что, билетировали у немцев?
Valerius Michelson: Да, это сделано почти со всеми студентами нашего университета.
David Boder: А кто...платит им кто-нибудь за квартиру?
Valerius Michelson: по последним...эээ...распоряжением должно платить немецкое правительство, или баварское правительство, точнее. До сих пор платили сами и сами зарабатывали себе деньги. Но надо сказать, что и сейчас...
David Boder: Как Вы зарабатываете?
Valerius Michelson: Я зарабатывал всё тем же: я по-прежнему рисовал, делал всякого рода...эээ...рисунки для раскрашивания и продавал их в немецких магазинах. И немецкие магазины их брали, так что в этом отношении немцы не оказывали мне никакого особого давления. [Пауза]
David Boder: Да, ну и...
Valerius Michelson: Некоторое время я работал здесь и в одной фирме. В фирме, которой, правда, руководит русский. Эээ...
David Boder: Какой русский?
Valerius Michelson: Некий инженер кайзера.
David Boder: Как же он может руководить [неразборчиво]?
Valerius Michelson: Здесь существует целый ряд фирм, большей частью руководимыми не только русскими, но очень много иностранцами: строительных фирм и инженерных фирм.
David Boder: Это новые, так сказать, фирмы?
Valerius Michelson: Это фирмы, которые создалися после того, как пришли американцы и освободили арестантов. Потому что здесь было достаточное количество вывезенных из России или вывезенных из Чехии или из других стран, оккупированных в своё время немцами, которые осталися здесь и которые работают и стараются работать, во всяком случае, для того, чтобы как-нибудь жить.
David Boder: И собираются тут остаться?
Valerius Michelson: В большинстве случаев, нет. Я не знаю ни одного случая, когда иностранцы хотели остаться...хотели бы остаться...
David Boder: Но почему это?
Valerius Michelson: Почему? Это я Вам скажу сейчас, вместе с разговором об университете для того, чтобы...
David Boder: Да, да, да, я Вас не буду перебивать.
Valerius Michelson: Я сам [пауза] узнал о том, что организуется при УНРРЕ университет. [Пауза] И пошёл в этот университет потому, что несмотря на моё знание немецкого языка и несмотря на то, что я знал, что есть определённая норма...приёма иностранцев в немецкие учебные заведения, считал, что идти к людям, которые начали эту войну и которые в свой психологии по прежнему ненавидят иностранцев - это значит идти в заведомо враждебную среду. С другой стороны, за время этой войны, особенно здесь, мне пришлось встретиться не только с русскими, пришедшими с востока, но и с поляками – частью, военнопленными, которые работали у крестьян, частью...эээ...людьми, вывезенными оттуда, - и с украинцами. И в последнее время с балтийцами. И у всех у них я заметил одну общую черту: черту желания после войны [пауза] каким-то образом построить жизнь на новых основах, особенно у молодёжи. На основах понимания друг друга и дружбы друг с другом. И мне казалось, что если этот университет, который сейчас создаётся, окрепнет, если этот университет [пауза] окажется, действительно...эээ..., единицей, которая может жить и существовать, то он может принести настоящую работу друг с другом. И особенно нас, людей с востока, которые, как я успел заметить в эти последние три года, никак не могли сговориться о том, чтобы быть дружными между собою. Они хотели этого, но каждый раз думали: «Нет, я - украинец. Я – поляк. Мы не можем быть вместе». Или: «Я - украинец, а ты москаль, русский. Ты...эээ...угнетаешь нашу национальность и так далее». И мне казалось, что в этом университете мы, молодёжь, которая станет [пауза], когда достаточно подготовится, руководящей в своих странах, в своих государствах. Если мы будем дружны между собой, то мы сумеем и наши государства сблизить так, как это нужно для того, чтобы не было ни войн, ни [пауза] этих ужасных тоталитарных режимов, которые унижают и человека, и его способность мыслить и творить на благо других людей. И с этой мыслью я пришел в университет. Первое, что я увидел в университете, [пауза] что такой идеи нет, что люди пришли сюда для того, чтобы после долгих лет оторванности от учения учиться. Это было хорошо. Но [пауза] это было не все. Здесь не хватало сплоченности, и поэтому не хватало студенческого, академического духа. [Пауза] И в первом же месяце [пауза] я, у нас, значит, на факультете, стал говорить о том, чтоб для того, чтобы жить по настоящему дружно, для того, чтобы создать себе условия существования академические, не похожие на средний ДП лагерь – как это очень многие из нас переживали и из которых очень многие ушли по той же причине, по которой ушёл я – нам нужно держаться вместе. И требовать к нам отношения иного, чем к средней массе. К нам отношение как к студенту, как к учащейся молодёжи.
David Boder: Какое же это особое отношение к студенту университета?
Valerius Michelson: Это я могу описать по примеру, который не так давно у нас был в лагере. Я думаю, что Вам это будет интересно. У нас здесь была забастовка. Самая настоящая голодная...голодный бунт, я бы сказал. Эээ...это казалось бы странным. Однако причины к нему были такие, что когда студенты пришли однажды утром в свой университет, то их не пускала в университет так называемая ДП полиция, т.е. ДП, которые были организованы для того, чтобы поддерживать порядок.
David Boder: ДП – значит «дисплейст персон»?
Valerius Michelson: Эти ДП...эта ДП полиция возмутила студентов уже одним своим видом, потому что привычно, что в университетах полиция не полагается. Но самое странное было, что она позволяла себе, во-первых, толкать и гонять студентов из угла в угол, и когда пришла наша профессура, то, задержав проректора университете, подвергала ему...еготщательному...эээ...обыску, заставляла его показывать различные документы и чрезвычайно грубо с ним обходилась. Это возмутило студентов больше всего. Затем целый ряд пожилых профессоров, для того чтобы войти в университет, должны были прыгать через скамейки, в том числе одна дама,...эээ...микробиолог, уважаемая нами как профессор, была вынуждена проделать то же самое. И это послужило причиной того, что студенты страшно начали шуметь и буквально были выведены из себя. [Пауза] Мне как председателю студенческой организации в нашем университете, конечно, было очень трудно успокоить расходившихся студентов. С большим трудом, созвав всех студентов во двор университета я убедил людей успокоиться, не устраивать каких-нибудь больших дебошей, и если уж они обязательно хотят что-нибудь сделать, то я согласился на требования большей части студентов постановить не брать нашего питания, не есть до тех пор, пока нам не обещают убрать полицию и убрать полицейские методы из нашего университета. Забастовка длилась всего-навсего один день. Всего только два раза, но онапоказала, что за те шесть месяцев, которые мы провели в университете, все студенты, без различия национальности или веры, сплотились в такую семью, что даже на такое рискованное дело, как забастовка, пошли все, совершенно солидарно. Это, конечно, только пример. Пример того, как...что мы считаем неправильным отношение к студентам и что вызывает наше возмущение. Именно поэтому мы говорим об академическом духе и об отношениях.
David Boder: Но позвольте! Что вам объяснили? Каким образом вся эта полицейская история произошла?
Valerius Michelson: Произошла по ошибке. По большой ошибке...
David Boder: [Неразборчиво, очень тихо]
Valerius Michelson: Совершенно верно, но мне кажется, что по отношению к студентам, такие ошибки не допустимы. Да и вообще по отношению к людям, не только к студентам. Всё-таки существуют определённые нормы поведения.
David Boder: Да, но здесь же театр военных действий был...
Valerius Michelson: Это верно. Но, тем не менее, я думаю, что мы не подали повода для того, чтобы с нами обращались таким образом. Мы стараемся [неразборчиво] вести себя корректно, и [пауза] я лично считаю, что эта забастовка была очень нехорошим делом, я...лично она не нравиться, постольку поскольку это было некорректно так делать.
Valerius Michelson: Некорректно было устраивать забастовки и так далее. Я думаю, что можно было бы даже договориться и без этого. Но это вызвано было тем, что это не первый случай был, и поэтому [неразборчиво] в таком настроении было.
David Boder: Я думаю, что Вы должны объяснить, что Дойчес Мюзиум – не только университет; тут также находиться вообще центр для прохода ДП.
Valerius Michelson: Совершенно верно.
David Boder: Вероятно, когда под это поставили полицию [неразборчиво] тут поставили полицию, им точно не сказали, какие посты...эээ...так сказать, охранять, и какие являются свободными.
Valerius Michelson: К сожалению, это не имело место. Дело в том, что вход был с двух сторон – с одной стороны входят ДП, а это было направленно специально по отношению к студентам, потому что в этот день...эээ...проводилась проверка посещений лекций, которая и без того уже студенчество по собственной инициативе – постольку, поскольку мы не хотим иметь в нашем университете бездельников и людей, которые только для того пришли в университет, чтобы пользоваться благами, которые [неразборчиво] очень благодарны, а для того...эээ...чтобы учиться. И тех людей, которые учатся, мы хотим иметь в нашем университете. Поэтому мы проводили через нашу студенческую организацию эту самую регистрацию и могли дать сведения о том, кто был и так далее.
David Boder: Да.
Valerius Michelson: На этот раз произошла ошибка.
David Boder: - Ну, [Пауза] есть ещё что-нибудь, что бы Вы хотели нам сказать? Или что бы Вы хотели сказать американскому студенчеству?
Valerius Michelson: Американскому студенчеству я бы хотел сказать следующее: что студенты- иностранцы здесь, которые собралися в нашем университете и которые в очень большой части штудируют в университетах немецких, все сейчас стараются сплотиться вместе, стараются перебороть всякую ненависть между национальностями, которые в Европе до сих пор, увы, ещё очень сильна, для того, чтобы работать для построения госу...в...своих государств в духе содружества с остальными, в духе действительного общечеловеческого содружества для того, чтобы не было событий, подобных прошедшей войне. Не было событий, подобных канувшему в вечность гитлеровскому государству. И мы хотим создания интернационального университета. Мы знаем, что то, что у нас сейчас здесь в Мюнхене – это не интернациональный университет, или, вернее, это интернациональный, но ещё не университет, потому что у нас ещё очень многого не хватает. Нас самих даже, в нашем мировоззрении, в наших...эээ...возможностях, чтобы называть себя настоящим интернациональным университетом. Но мы думаем, что мы можем послужить ядром для такого содружества и для такого университета, который воспитает интеллигенция для будущего. Вот, собственно, всё.
David Boder: [In English] So. This concludes the interview of Mr. Valerius Michelson, a student of architecture at the International University of UNRRA. Munich, September the 24th, 1946. We had here quite some interruptions of some very important visitors which I could not stave away, and from that standpoint we have lost quite a bit some time. An Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.